I had everything that a 33-year-old man
is supposed to want. Six-figure salary,
I was vice president of an Inc. 5000
marketing company, 401K, profit share,
remote job, benefits, a team of 35
people. On paper, I was killing it. But
I did something that I may one day
regret. I quit. With a wife and three
kids and a mortgage and having to figure
out health insurance and all that stuff,
I quit my VP career so I can build a
one-person business writing online. And
in this video, I'm going to tell you
exactly why I quit and the exact
framework that I used to build my
one-person business while working my VP
career. And it's the same framework that
I'm using today to scale my one-person
business. I'm not going to give you some
sort of this is what you should do. I'm
going to peel back the curtain and show
you exactly what I'm doing on the
screen, my actual business numbers,
content, all of that stuff. So stick
around. But first, walk you through why
I left. So the most obvious reason of
why I left my career is that I didn't
want to work for someone else. But when
you think through that, right? Everybody
says that. I don't want to work for
anyone else. I want to work for myself.
I don't want to have a boss and all
these things. I couldn't make the jump
with just that kind of mindset because
I've got a wife and kids and family and
stuff like that. I'm not like quitting
McDonald's and and dumping my $9 an hour
salary. That's not what this is. This is
a six-figure job with opportunities to
climb the ladder, remote and ownership
and all of these things. This was a
bigger decision than most people think.
And so I had to dig the layers deeper.
In fact, I went one to two to three
layers deeper that I want to unpack with
you, which may actually help you in your
decision to either stay or quit your
job. And the first layer of that that I
really had to unpack is what Why don't I
want to work for someone else? What is
What is holding me back cuz I have this
really good circumstances. I'm making
good money. Like what is it? And and one
layer deeper was I want more control
over my time and my money. And and the
word that I really use for myself is
autonomy. I want autonomy over my time
and my money. And after wrestling with
that, I had to go in layer even deeper
and I realized, well, why do I want more
control over my time and my money? I
make good money and and my time like I I
work remote. Like it's not too bad. Like
why do I want more control over that?
And the thing that I kept coming back to
is, well, I don't want to outsource my
success and growth to be dependent on
other people's decisions. You inherit
the consequences
of other people's decisions and that
affects your own success and growth.
That is the sentence in the line that
came to me that I started realizing,
that's it. That's the reason why I want
to build my own one-person business
because I want to have full control over
the opportunities, the success, the
growth in my personal life as opposed to
inheriting the consequences of all the
people around me, their decisions, what
they want to do, and all of this stuff.
No matter how much influence you have,
you, if you work anywhere, you have to
inherit those consequences. Those
consequences affect your life, which
means it affects where you live, what
car you drive, how you provide for your
family, how much time you spend with
your kids. It affects all of those
things and I didn't want any of that.
Think about it practically. Even as the
vice president of a company, if the CEO
walks in and says, "I've got this great
idea for a new product that I want to
launch." And I don't agree with him,
well, I still have to launch that
product. And if that product doesn't go
well, think about how my head is going
to swirl. Oh, man, I didn't like that
product anyway. I didn't think it was
going to work. I said it wasn't going to
work. But should I say that I said it
wasn't going to work? Right now, you
have to inherit the consequences that
that product didn't work. It wasn't your
decision. It didn't go well. Now you
make less money and you spent lots of
time and hours and meetings and all of
these things launching a product that
you don't give a crap about. Now amplify
that times five, six, seven, right? What
if the operations team is not making the
systems and the processes that you would
agree with? What if they don't want to
try AI because they're legacy people and
Donna in accounting is like, I don't
know what AI is and you're like, well,
it could save you a bunch of time and
money. Like, we don't want to try this?
Now I'm obviously portraying the
negative side. There's a lot of good
side to where you work with good people
and and you have good systems and all
these things and you get to inherit
those consequences as well, but
depending on how you're wired, you have
a natural knack to saying, I'm naturally
ambitious. I naturally have drive. I
naturally really know what I want to do
and that's just me. That's who I am. And
so because I have those things, you
wrestle with these two resources. The
first resource being time. Spending time
building someone else's thing where you
inherit the consequences and you don't
have all the decision-making power. You
are spending the best time and energy of
your life. Okay? Think about it. 9:00 to
5:00 p.m. Think about how much energy
and time in your prime years. Like I'm a
33-year-old man. I'm in my prime earning
years. I'm in my prime learning and
thinking years. This is when I can do
the best work of my life. Even if you're
in your 40s, your 50s, your 60s, like
all of those things, you're still in the
prime of your life to build something
meaningful and where you spend your time
is going to control the destiny of where
you outcome. And so if you're investing
all of your time, meaning all of your
creative and energy and you're coming
home brain fried and you have no energy
for anything else, that's going to
affect who you are in five years, in 10
years, in 15 years, in 20 years. This is
why I think there's a huge epidemic
happening, especially in the United
States, where people just, you know,
they commute an hour to work, they spend
eight hours a day, they're just frying
their brains and they commute an hour
home and they just pick up fast food and
veg on Netflix for the rest of the day
because they have no more energy or time
to do anything else. They are fried. And
I just didn't want to become like that,
which is what happens, right? People
become the best employees they could
possibly be, but the worst version of
themselves at the same time. Because all
of your time and energy is going into
growing this company, because someone
else wants to scale, and someone else
wants to have more awards, and have this
big company, and corner office, and all
this stuff. And And me, on the flip
side, I'm like, I just want to have
breakfast with my family, drink
espresso, write words on the internet,
read books, and and be healthy. Like, I
don't want all of this stuff. And so,
now, I don't want to inherit the
consequences of someone who does want
all of this stuff, and I don't want to
be the one that helps them get it at the
consequence of my life. Which leads to
the second resource that we are giving
up by not doing this sooner, and that is
the opportunity cost of building your
own thing. Think about it. The longer
you wait to build a one-person business
you love, the longer it takes to do it,
and the less time you have to do it. So,
I'm 33 now. I started building my
one-person business at 29. I'm 4 years
into this, and I'm still nowhere near
the goal that I want to be for my
one-person business, but man, I'm a heck
of a lot further than 99% of people.
Especially those who never start,
because they don't know how to start.
They don't have a system. They don't
have the energy to do it. They don't
know how to do it while having a
full-time job, which I'm going to solve
all of that for you in this video, okay?
We're going to walk through all of those
things. But, that opportunity cost
starts to stack and compound against
you. It's kind of like investing in a
bank account, but negatively. The longer
you wait, the more negative it
compounds, because now you have less
energy, less time, less drive, less
ambition. I'm 33, but what happens when
I'm 43? When I'm 53? When I'm 63? You're
running out of the time to be able to do
this. And eventually, you just end up
retired, you climb the corporate ladder,
you look back, and you have one of the
top regrets that most people have on
their deathbed is, I wish I would have
worked less, or I wish I would have been
myself more, or I wish I would have done
the things that I wanted to do. All of
those things happen revolving around the
career energy. Cuz think about 40, 50
hours a week, that is your life. And so
I knew I needed to figure out a way to
do my own thing. I have my own
ambitions. I want to build my own thing,
and the thing that I don't want to do is
I I don't want to build an agency. I
don't want to build a client based
business, cuz that's the same as having
a boss, except now you have multiple
bosses. I don't want to be at the whims
of someone else telling me, "This is
what I want you to do, and this is the
thing I need you to make, and this is
the product that we're shipping." I
don't want to build that. I want to
build my own business where I sell my
own stuff, my own products, I create my
own content, I build everything around
my life, my energy, my lifestyle, and
I'm not at the demands of anyone else.
Which when you go look at how to do
that, especially in the creator economy,
you get a bunch of YouTubers and content
creators who tell you need to build a
big social media audience and create all
this content, and then, you know, do
affiliate sales and and and affiliate
commissions and all this stuff. And it
was I was like, "This is not
sustainable. First off, this is stupid.
This is not sustainable. How can you
expect someone to build a 100,000
audience, 200,000 audience, 300,000 like
you don't need that big of an audience
to be able to monetize." I've been in
marketing my whole life. I saw half the
internet was from 19-year-old dum-dums
out there who have no idea what they're
talking about. And the other flip side
of that is most of the advice that you
see online is not sustainable. I can't
sustain a life with a wife and three
kids and a mortgage and all that. I
can't bet on affiliate commissions and a
social media audience and things like
that. Like none of that made sense. So I
invested in coaching and mentorship in
building a business off my 15 years of
marketing experience, and I've created a
framework that I used to build my one
person business while having my vice
president career. So I was able to do
this part-time while having a full-time
career because the process is so simple,
because it makes so much sense, because
it's so clear. I needed something that
stupid simple that I could show up every
day and know exactly what to do, get the
results I needed to get and actually
grow this thing. If it wasn't that
simple, I wouldn't be here where I am
today. So, if you're looking for that
stupid simple one-person business model
of writing online, then awesome. I'm
going to walk you through I'm going to
pull back the curtain, okay? You don't
need a huge audience for this. You don't
need to be a social media guru. You
don't need any of that stuff and I'm
going to show you how, okay? What's on
my screen here is something called the
ARC framework. I made this for myself,
okay? I use this because I needed a
system that I could stick to that I knew
what was I doing, why was I doing it,
and is this the best use of my time?
Because I only had 1 to 2 hours a day to
build this freaking thing. And so, if I
was only going to be able to invest an
hour or two a day into building my
one-person business, I had to know that
the time that I was putting in was the
most valuable way that I can put my
time. So, I broke out my business into
three stepping stones. That's it. It's
just three stepping stones. What it
stands for is audience, relationship,
continuity. And I'm going to walk you
through every single one of those, okay?
So, let's walk through what this looks
like. The first thing is building a
customer-based creator-style business,
writing online, using the internet. You
need an audience. You do need an
audience. Does it need to be a million
followers? No, and I'm going to show you
why. But first, you have to understand
you do need people. Traffic is the most
important part of your business because
if you don't have traffic, you don't
have customers. You don't have people
buying stuff from you. You don't have
people whose problems you can solve,
right? So, if you don't have that, it's
not going to help you. Now, there's two
ways that you can build a social media
audience. You can build it with organic
content or you can build it with paid
content. And it just really depends on
the resource that you want to trade more
of, right? If you want to build organic
content, that's going to cost you time.
It's going to cost you energy. But if
you want to build it with paid ads, paid
content, then that's going to cost you
money. So, do you have more money or do
you have more time? Hilarious enough, I
actually had more money than I did time,
but I didn't run the paid ads route
because of step two in my business
model, and that is relationship. The
reason I actually chose to opt into
organic content, specifically a YouTube
channel, was because I wanted to build
something that had a compounding effect.
Meaning, if I ran paid ads for my
business, the minute I turn off those
paid ads is the minute that I stop
getting customers. It's the minute that
people stop engaging with me. So, I knew
I'm still on the lever of someone else's
whims. But, with organic content,
especially evergreen content, I knew
that it would compound over time. So, me
creating this YouTube video can be seen
6 months from now, a year from now, 2
years from now, and it will still help
people because it's an asset that I put
into the digital atmosphere. So, what
I've been doing, like if I pop over to
my screen, I have my YouTube channel
primarily. I did start on Twitter. I was
writing primarily on Twitter, and I grew
my Twitter to about 6,000 followers, but
the reason that I moved away from
Twitter to YouTube was that evergreen
aspect, because you can make a thread, a
tweet, and then it's dead tomorrow,
right? It either does well or it doesn't
do well, and so you're constantly
putting out this content, and these
assets don't work in your favor. But,
with YouTube, I have about 4,000
followers right now, 159 videos, and I
drop a video, probably two, three videos
a month. And so, when you look at my
videos, I'm talking about writing
online. So, I'm helping people write and
be copywriters and sell through writing.
So, I'll create a video like these,
write content like this, and that is my
primary growth driver. Now, one thing
you'll notice is, again, this is not
like a crazy number. In fact, my channel
is way underrated. You guys need to hit
the like and the subscribe to this
channel. This channel is way underrated
for the content and the quality that I'm
putting out. But, the idea being, my
content is targeted at a very specific
person, okay? I am targeting someone who
wants to write and build a one-person
business. So, I have a very specific
person in mind that my content resonates
with. That is the first part of this
whole model. You have to have a platform
that you want to create content on. My
hack for this one is you need to pick
the platform you enjoy the most. I know
I talked about evergreen, not evergreen,
and you're like, "Oh, man, maybe I
should build on YouTube and things like
that." You need to pick the platform
that you enjoy the most because you have
to be sustainable. You have to do this
for a long time. You're not going to
build a one-person business in 20 days,
in 30 days, in 3 months, right? It's
going to take a year, 2 years, 3 years.
And so, you have to pick the platform
you have fun building on, otherwise
you're going to quit. I love YouTube. I
love creating these. I love teaching
content. And so, when you see all of
this stuff, I'm excited to make this
content, and I know it's going to last
for a long time and that you're
thoroughly going to enjoy it. Now, the
next thing that happens is you're going
to click a video like this one, okay?
And what happens is I'm going to teach a
lot of content in this video. I'm going
to give away value for free. So, I'm
showing my authority of what I know
about copywriting and writing and all of
these things. So, I'm going to give away
all of that content. But, there's a next
phase to this ARC framework. Now, this
is the main hack, okay, for the audience
thing. The reason you don't need a
massive audience on social media to be
able to build a thriving business is
because social media is what grows my
audience, but it's not what grows my
overall relationship with my audience.
You see, the relationship with the
audience is really the thing that
they're buying. They're not buying your
product, they're not buying your
community, they're not buying your
coaching, they're buying you. And And
more that they know you, hear from you,
talk to you, the better relationship
that they have. And so, one of the
things that YouTube does really well is
it creates this this starter
relationship with people where they get
to know you, they see you on camera,
they read your writing, or whatever it
is. But, you cannot control the
consistency and the pace that they
actually see you, right? I could put a
YouTube video up and maybe they don't
have the bell turned on, or maybe they
haven't been scrolling YouTube or
anything like that. And so, they don't
hear from me for a week, for 2 weeks,
for 3 weeks. So, they don't strengthen
their relationship with you to actually
start to know you better and actually
want to buy your stuff because you solve
their problem. And so, what I do is in
my YouTube videos, what I actually do is
I plug what I consider bribes to join my
email list. I'm offering you a gift like
a welcome gift. Hey, if you want this
gift, you can click one of these links
down below, it'll help you solve a
problem, and all I need is your email in
exchange. So, one of the bribes that I
have for this one, the become
dangerously persuasive, my 2-hour
masterclass on copywriting. Which
copywriting is the most underrated skill
for building a one-person writing
business, okay? So, on here, I have a
2-hour course training presentation that
I actually go through in this video. So,
in this video, I walk them through this
presentation, which is super cool. I put
the link down below, and I have a bunch
of other links for products and things
like that that people can get for free.
And when they click that link, they open
up a page like this. And this is what I
call a lead magnet page. It's your bribe
page. And basically, what you're doing
is in exchange for someone's email
address, which is way more direct
communication than YouTube or Twitter or
social media or anything like that. In
exchange for their email address, I will
send you a gift. And that's what I did
here, how to go from a beginner to a
paid writer by becoming dangerously
persuasive with copywriting in just 2
hours. And I have this modern-day
copywriting crash course. So, somebody's
going to put in their email, I'm going
to put in my email, right? I'm going to
hit send me the crash course, and what
happens is they join my email list.
Which leads us to the second part of the
ARC framework, which is relationship.
This is huge. Most people, especially in
the creator economy, miss this. They
just make YouTube videos or they make
Twitter and then they try and sell their
stuff. Doesn't work like that. Twitter
hates when you put links in stuff. And
the YouTube algorithm is up and down and
up and down. They could nerf it, they
could change it, and you don't own
direct communication. So, let's say you
put a video up and your people don't
have the bell subscribed or they don't
check Twitter, whatever it is. Or the
algorithm doesn't feed them the video
that week because it doesn't think it's
relevant. You are at the whims of the
algorithm. So, I took the algorithm
completely out of place because,
remember again, I can't sit here and bet
on things that could happen to grow my
business. I needed a foolproof, simple
plan to grow my one-person business. And
email has just been around for over two
decades working beautifully, flawlessly.
It hasn't changed. People still check
their email every day. And in fact, I
actually send an email every single day.
This is part of my business model. Is
that I send an email every day because
my key philosophy is relationship. So,
think about it. You know how most people
send one email a week and it's this long
newsletter and it has all this crap in
it and it's formatted like ChatGPT wrote
it and it's all bull crap. Think about
if you had a relationship with your
spouse. Like if I I have my wife. What
if every Sunday at 7:00 p.m. I sat down
and that's the one time that I talk to
my wife. I'm like, "Hey, how was your
week? Here's a brain dump of all the
stuff that happened to me this week.
What do you think about that?" That's
what a weekly email newsletter feels
like to me and it just it doesn't make
any sense to me because again, I'm
trying to optimize for relationship. I
want to know you better and you know me
better. So, I write a daily email so
that every morning it's like me having
an espresso with my wife. I sit down, I
grab an espresso and I say, "How was
your day? How are you doing? Here's an
incredible story that I think you're
going to absolutely love." And she
laughs and we hang out. She loves me.
All the good things happen because she
hears from me every day. People think,
"Well, one email a day, that's going to
annoy people. It's going to piss people
off. I'm going to get a bunch of
unsubscribes." Yes, but you'll also get
the most loyal fans possible because the
people who stick around on your email
list are your true fans. They're very
much like Kevin Kelly's 1,000 true fans.
This is how my entire business model was
built out because with a 4,000 person
subscriber based audience, I don't need
20,000 people who buy from me. I need
1,000 really great customers who buy
everything from me. This is how this is
based. It's actually much simpler than
it looks. My daily emails look something
like this. Like when I go to
alandragoo.com, my daily emails go here
and they go to my blog, but really you
get them on my email list, right? This
is where you get the most access, but
this is what the emails look like. Look,
July 31st, July 30th, July 29th, July
28th, July 27th, right? Like you see
this. And so, I'm going to hit this and
this is what my emails look like. Okay?
My emails are really fun 300 to 500 word
emails that are very story driven. Okay?
I'm not trying to teach you something
every day. I've actually flipped the way
that people do one person business. A
lot of time when people are trying to
build an audience, they do entertainment
to attract that audience and then they
do education via email if they do a
weekly email or whatever they're doing.
I flip it. I do education to build my
audience to prove that I know what the
crap I'm talking about and then I do
entertainment because email is
inherently boring. I mean, it's words on
a page. So, if I can entertain someone
via email, I can get them to open
tomorrow's email and the next day email
and the next day email. So, I use this
framework called the slow framework,
story lesson offer. I've got an entire
video on the slow framework. You go out
I'll put a card above. You can watch
that, enjoy that, and learn exactly how
I write, structure, and send my emails.
But, the basic of the SLOW framework is
I tell a very compelling story that's
incredibly fun and entertaining in my
world, so they get to know me better and
my life, and they get to resonate, "Hey,
I like this guy." Or, "Hey, I really
don't like this guy." And then, from
that SLOW framework, after I tell the
story, I give a lesson. So, this Like
this email right here, I'm talking about
one of my favorite books, Dungeon
Crawler Carl. I tell a crazy story about
it, and then I teach a marketing
copywriting lesson right here, and then
I make an offer to buy one of my
products. I have a course, it's $149.
At the end of the email, people will buy
it. And what happens when you send one
email a day? Well, even if you get one
to two sales a day of a $200 course, a
$149 course, a $99 product, right? That
ends up being three to five to 10 grand
at the end of the month, depending on
the amount of sales, even at just a
minimum amount of sales. But, this is
where things get really interesting
because while I was building my
one-person business, I realized, well, I
can't be at the whim of did this product
sell, did this product not sell. I did a
launch, I didn't do a launch, and the
the roller coaster of income, again,
another big problem that creators have,
is that they just launch courses, they
make a ton of money, and they're like,
"Oh, this course." And then they don't
make any money for 3 months. Well, I
needed a system. So, instead of just
selling a product, I sell a continuity
item on top of the other products that I
sell. In fact, my continuity product,
meaning they pay on recurring basis
subscription, is the baseline to
everything else I sell. And the way that
I do that is with my school community.
So, I use school, s k o o l, and I run a
club called the Copy Creator Club. Right
now, there's 113 members in here paying
me $50 a month, so it's about $5,300
a month, where I teach you how to build
a one-person business writing online.
Ding, ding, ding. So, if this video is
resonating with you and you like the ARC
framework, then this is a great place
for me to actually personally coach you.
This is a mentorship club, okay? People
send me private DMs asking me for help
and they they help each other in here,
right? So, there's people winning in
here and exclusive drops, bullet
trainings that I have masterclass
guests, people like Ben Settle, Daniel
Throssell, Parker Worth, right? Coaching
threads, people are printing out my
monthly newsletters. All of this stuff
that is happening inside of the club
that people are paying a subscription
base. But, that's just one of the ways
that you can create a continuity
product. You can have continuity in
coaching. In fact, one of my club
members,
Robin, Robin over here, Robin Timers, he
just launched his own continuity
coaching product and he just went
completely clientless. He doesn't have
clients anymore because now he coaches
full-time. So, he has customers who pay
him on a recurring basis for his
coaching. And he did that through an
email list. You know what his email list
size? It's somewhere in between 1,000 to
2,000 people. You don't need a huge
audience. Or maybe you have a newsletter
that you could sell, right? You could go
to Substack and go right on Substack.
Like, I have a Substack. It's got almost
300 subscribers on the Substack. It's
got paying subscribers and all those
things, right? It's not my bread and
butter by any means, but you could go
get paying subscribers on Substack and
that is a continuity model. If you have
1,000 people paying you $10 a month,
that's 10 grand a month. Is 1,000 people
crazy? No, it's not crazy. You don't
need 100,000 subscribers. You don't need
a million followers. You don't need an
email list that's 10,000 people. You
need 1,000 paying subscribers at $10 a
month or you can launch a community at
$50 a month, $100 a month. As long as
it's some sort of continuity model and
then on top of that, if you want to
create courses or do a 21-day challenge
or a cohort or anything like that,
selling the product that you sell,
awesome, beautiful, fantastic. You can
do those things and that's extra money.
So, I combine those two models. I have
the base of my continuity product, and
then from there, I sell other trainings
and courses and affiliate products and
things like that. And if you want to,
you could take on client work, you could
do a project here or there, but you
don't need to do those things because
you have a base income off your own
one-person business. This is the exact
structure that I've personally used and
personally still use to this day to
build my one-person writing online
business. I write my YouTube scripts,
then I record them right here, and then
I write my daily emails, and then I
write all the content in the community.
It's all writing. Everything that I do
is copywriting. The hook in this video,
the script in this video, my daily
emails to sell and persuade you on my
courses, the content that I sell and
persuade inside of my school community,
it's all copywriting. And if you haven't
mastered the art of copywriting, I'm
going to leave a gift down below, my 41
advanced copywriting secrets. That if
you study these, I guarantee you'll get
more attention, more clicks, more sales,
more subscribers, and more people opting
into your continuity product. 41
advanced secrets, get them down below.
Anything else you need, there's a couple
other gifts down there if it's more
helpful for you. But that is the entire
model. That is the system that I used to
leave the job so I can have more control
over my time and my income. I'm a normal
guy. I can do it, you can definitely do
it. This wasn't crazy for me, but if you
want me to coach you, if you want me to
help you, then I highly consider
clicking below, checking out the school
community, where you'll get my personal
mentorship, and get access to over 100
other people building their one-person
business. Either way, I hope this video
was helpful for you in your
decision-making and building your life
that you actually want to live, a
professional enjoyment lifestyle. Uh
like and subscribe to the channel, grab
any resources in the description below
that would be helpful for you. And if
you have any questions, you're more than
welcome to drop them in the comments
below. But other than that, I hope the
video was helpful. I appreciate you
watching, share it with a friend, and I
will catch you on the next one.